welcome to this video playing the
national master
selmak oh sure look maybe something like
that from Greece Canton let's play the
Moscow can Jason keep it simple lines
that's I think one idea with Queen e2
and Rock d1 try to to go for that
quickly one maybe c4b three years some a
possible continuation okay yeah well not
c3 I need to do anyway
maybe he's trying forth quick could play
against the C pawn okay I need to be
cautious be 3d five might be a
possibility
okay so I get I get the chance to
protect this guy don't think b5 is
possible at the moment so I have from a
nice setup here on the default I'm not
not really threatening much yeah this is
a passing move okay well maybe Bishop f6
so he wants to wants to go
okay let's get out of this tempo okay so
it's f45 an idea I'm probably not
a foreigner looks looks rather loose
hmm yeah this is the kind of position
where you somehow maybe get the
impression that okay white is enjoying a
bit of a space advantage but it's not
cleared of how you're going to make any
progress ah
the rook on the three actually blocks
this I shouldn't have allowed that hmm
now this is bad ah yeah
yeah I shouldn't have allowed that at
all how to continue I was thinking about
a very slow build-up with therefore and
so on this this is this is a bit weird
I'm not really attacking me five but
came
yeah this looks really silly yeah but I
simply forgot that he can play b5 and
this is really a big deal
nykänen claim we should be for now if he
wants
yeah I was thinking maybe a 45 but make
up leadership deform no wait but I can I
can actually I can yeah I can do that
and I should I should do that also
hoping for a bit of counterplay
yeah maybe his gaudy 5v5 a Glee move but
maybe it's okay
not at five Roxy - he didn't he didn't
do for that it was maybe maybe correct
okay need to push him no use in playing
a passive moves not sure that it really
helps me but I need to go forward okay
so some way - yeah if I move the light
as always Roxy - quite quite annoying
that is just a ticking deform
yes look see for what a crappy game now
came back and it's protected from the
fifth-ranked for the moment at least
hmm that's probably just f6 here yep
oopsy for now
why does it take so long for that Roxy
for him yeah always
just briefly think maybe it is working
after all but there is simply nothing
yeah just wow
white resigned just a stinker of a game
yeah I completely completely blundered
his b5 of course I can I simply
shouldn't allow it and then it is
nothing nothing much happening here just
a normal position
with no particular problem or anything
okay the whole idea g3 f4 is probably
nonsense but just just allowing a b5 is
spared I mean I can even just play it
for him and prevent him to play b5 with
no problem at all can maybe even go here
it's nothing happening I simply forgot
that I haven't protected the b v square
and this is a position where white is
just in very bad shape I have no plan at
all there's always this undermining
undermining a form not a form and yeah
just a very bad position even if the
computer still think this is quite
playable it is just just terrible Wow
thanks for watching